ねピントがここにあってんだよなぁいやいよ
ピントが完全にそれをやってんだよなぁなぜ私がいい
スポットに行くかといいますと結局は恐いもの見たいんですよ
たらなんでピント所やぼれにあったよまずで濃いんだけど米韓があるわけじゃないんで
怖いもの見たさでついて言っちゃう
ですけども先日後輩といった愛知県と静岡の間のトンネルの道があったと思うんです
けども
前の後編
皆さん
ご覧になられたでしょうか内部んだったカオスれたんですけどそもそも車のフロント
ないとが急にチュール戦でもおかしいと思うべきだったんですけどコメント欄とかで見
ておかせな場所がありなっ
思いましてまあそれがこちらんですけどもういい加減ですね
スペシャルな内容です
いいと思います戦争なんだよ
思ってルーター5分34秒
もう一度ご覧いただきましょうどうぞともいい加減です今日は
スペシャルならないよこの後んだと思います
戦争なんだよん
[音楽]
分かりませんでしょうか
ビニール袋がが坂ざっとなったと明らかに
僕でもなく後輩君ではない別の方の声が
入っています
と言いたいところなんですけどもうねひょっとしたら何かベスト4へじゃないかとか僕
の声か
masaya 公園の声が入っていただけなんじゃねぇかったポッポ思ってあまり気に
してなかったんですけどもはっきりとそうじゃないってことを最近ちょっと吊って
しまいましてねこれはの水玉リボンどのかんだからちょっと
連絡が来て水玉リボンドラ bg 分作ってくれて
gtk さんという方がいるんですけどもその方がですね
先日あの心霊動画の声声の部分を果せ分析してくださったらしいですその音声分析して
いただいた結果
誰の声でもないという結論に至ったらしいですね
山沢 the 温泉分析するのも面白いんですけどなんか動画も作ってくださった
みたいなので10尾の釣果
どうぞ
入ってるぜ
[拍手]
スペシャルならない
思いますねそうなんだよ
思って youtube 今日ねー
なんでと思ったからもう一回見てみましょう4
入ってください
ge 2
火加減です今日はスペシャルな内容です
良いと思います戦争なんだよん
思って youtube 共鳴
前で使ったほうがいいん
見方がわからないな目で見方が分からないんですけども多分音声的に言うとここの
うめき声の場所をと的に言うと僕の声でもないし
ませんの声もないそこにいた誰の声でもないと言う
結論にとってますね
そしてこの心霊スポットに行った後特に何も大きてないんですけど風邪をひいたじゃ
ないかな心霊スポットに行った次の20校風邪引いちゃって石器とか結構出たんです
けども今
治ってないじゃん
やっぱいて見返してみると
女の人の声が入っていて誰の声でもなかったっていう検証結果も出たので
いいねよくよくはないんですけど入ってみて今回ですね
正堅倉の結果あれば誰の声でもなかったということがわかってしまったんですけどもね
あそこ
結構の心霊スポット目だけで行くところじゃないんですけどもこういうことが起きて
詰まったということでおっ
引き続き
やっぱりちょっと待ってガムテープ覚えてねまったく覚えてる声出るまで言わればいい
んじゃないってよねはいというわけでちょっとあの結構萌えてますけども
せ10匹は皆さんもお気をつけて
me
[音楽]